[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in michael k the s
network yankees play-by-play announcer
um the
pre-game show on yes starts tonight at
six eastern game coverage with mike
david cohen paul o'neill begins at seven
with the astros there did uh how did
last night
play out in accordance to what you
thought it was going to play out as far
as the atmosphere mike
yeah the atmosphere was amazing dan um
it was probably the
the best atmosphere for a baseball game
since the alcs in 2019 so
they didn't have any fans last year uh
this year there's been about ten
thousand fans nine thousand ten thousand
fans in every home game it's
it's been lively when you compare it to
nobody but yesterday ten thousand eight
hundred and fifty fans
actually sounded like a crowd of fifty
thousand they were loaded for bear they
wanted to pay back the astros
then waiting storing this up it was uh
it was definitely a postseason
atmosphere to tell you the truth
i i don't know what your feelings were
when this first came out that they had
won the world series and then there was
the cheating there uh
we know the players weren't punished it
was the manager and the gm but
what should baseball have done
well obviously they kind of made the
quote-unquote deal with the devil dan
where in order for the players to admit
what they did they were granted immunity
so you couldn't punish them
after that i understand that that's all
part of of doing business that way and
getting
um some kind of uh admission on paper
but what they should have done i don't
understand why they didn't and nobody's
ever really
given me a good explanation is they
should have taken away
the world series trophy and the world
series title if you do that
then the players can't walk around with
a ring and uh you know 50 years from now
say they were world champions
in 2017 and i think that's what angers
the fans
and it doesn't get the yankees the
chance to play in the world series in
2017
it doesn't get the dodgers the
championship in 2017
but at least there's some kind of
justice that's extracted
for what they did now would they do it
again well why wouldn't they do it again
the players weren't punished at all yeah
yeah i said the same thing like what's
the deterrent it's like robinson cano is
still playing baseball and he should be
out of baseball
you get popped twice i mean come on what
what is the deterrent anymore
uh uh altuve ended up signing a contract
that he's making close to 30 million
dollars a year
like okay so it's tainted i'm still
making all this money but
i don't know d is there any sympathy for
the astros
like kelto like last night as you're
watching this any sympathy
it's funny you ask that because i think
they all deserve
the greeting that they got in the bronx
and i expected it i think it's going to
be worse tonight
but i i felt a little bit sorry for
altuve
and here's why this guy was one of the
most likable players in all of baseball
he was a guy that people said wow
if he could make it anybody could make
it or against all odds
he became this great player and if he
thinks that yesterday
is just a one-shot deal it's not as long
as he plays this game
he is going to be the villain now so he
turned into the fake from the favorite
to the villain and did he really need to
cheat are his talents enough that
if he didn't know the signs would he
still have been a great player and i
still believe he would have been
but now he's got this scarlet letter
attached to him for all time
and he's going to be booed until the end
of his career and i kind of feel sorry
for him a bit
but there's levels of cheating though
michael like that's
that's the hard part when you you know
we can do like
baseball cheating where i'm at second
base and i can look in and see where the
catcher is situated whatever
but you know you got steroids in here
uh so it's kind of hard to go okay
doctoring a baseball
like like what is hey that's okay that's
the game and then
what is not okay you know
it's kind of like the old supreme court
uh decision on pornography i'll know it
when i see it you know
it's kind of like you have to judge it
for yourself like when the red sox were
punished for 2018
dan i thought that was gamesmanship all
right they studied the catcher signs on
a video
then they told their players what the
signs would be when a guy got to second
base
he actually transferred that to the
batter i think that's gamesmanship
but banging trash cans and having a live
camera in the dugout
uh in center field and transferring it
into the alleyway the dugout
to me that was cheating and the astros
no it was cheating and then you know the
humorous thing was
that they've come out then and said well
we didn't do it in the postseason oh
okay i'll play along
so it worked all of the season but you
didn't do it in the postseason
and another reason why i think the
yankees are still upset uh
labor torres said this a year ago okay
it worked in 2017 and you won a world
series
you all of a sudden stopped in 18 and 19
you hadn't been caught yet
why would you all of a sudden stop did
you have this pang of guilt
the whole thing is still messy and i'll
tell you the truth a lot of people in
the yankee organization
think that things weren't in the up and
up in 2019 either
when altuve hit that walk-off home run
against chapman but that's never been
proven
well it's like when andy pettit said hey
i just did it to come back from an
injury i used steroids and then i
stopped i don't know any
anybody who stops unless you have to
stop
and you know so that's another you know
that's more individual this was systemic
this was an
organization but has garrett cole ever
talked about
you're a pitcher on the astros you
benefited
even if like you're in the dugout like
did you hear the trash can being banged
did you did you see the results of some
of this
did they keep it a secret from the
pitching staff has as cole ever
commented on
you know what he knew and when he knew
it well it's funny
they didn't keep it a secret from mike
fires when he told the athletics so he's
the one who blew the whole lid off of it
but
he has been very quiet about it you know
he's answered some questions but he
hasn't been expansive and he's one of
the best athletes i've ever seen
in answering questions really thinking
about them but uh you know he's saying
that when he was there he didn't see
anything and
he just leaves it at that because uh you
know there hasn't been any proof that in
those years they had done anything wrong
but in 2017
there actually is proof so i guess he
could you know walk around it that way
is there a rivalry with the mets and
yankees now is it
you know legitimate
i think if the mets end up being really
good you know those six games could be
exciting i i really think dan that the
inner league play has kind of been
played now
it's been over done the six games a year
is too much and unless they're both
really good
i don't know if it's going to be the
same sort of rivalry i think the
rivalries now are with the astros the
race and the red sox and
the mets are more of a fun thing uh but
if they get good and you know there's a
battle for the city
and you know both fan bases get really
into it i think that will ignite
that again but i think it's those three
teams in the america that the yankees
really
have a rivalry with great to catch up
with you michael my best to uh paul and
david thanks we'll be watching tonight
thanks dan have a great one that's
michael k the yes
network yankees play-by-play announcer
paul o'neill david cohn
their festivities start at six eastern
tonight on yes